la prima volta che ho sentito parlare di
Bolca ero all'università e il professore
ci raccontava che sui Monti Lessini
c'era un paesino famosissimo per i suoi
pesci fossili un sito di importanza
internazionale dove In questi fossili
potevamo trovare persino le tracce della
pelle a me al nome Monti Lessini venne
subito in mente un paesaggio montano
chiaramente con il pesino di Bolca
incastonato tra le montagne Adesso
invece da paleontologa penso ogni volta
che penso a Bolca in realtà penso al
mare e non un marito qualunque ma un
mare tropicale immaginatevi di poter
viaggiare nel tempo e di tornare
indietro di 48 milioni di anni vi
trovereste immersi nelle acque di un
Mare Caldo e pieno di vita oppure a
camminare su una spiaggia popolata da
Foreste di mangrovie è il classico
paradiso terrestre che sono sicuri tutti
noi almeno una volta nella vita vorremmo
visitare
questo posto così esotico così lontano
da quello che è oggi il nostro
territorio era proprio qui a Bolca Ma
come facciamo a sapere che in passato
qui a volta c'era il mare come facciamo
noi paleontologi ad esserne sicuri la
prova innegabile sono i fossili i resti
di organismi che oggi non esistono più e
che sono racchiusi all'interno delle
rocce che formano le montagne questi
fossili sono eccezionalmente preservati
e questo lo sanno tutti i membri della
comunità scientifica perché qui
riusciamo a trovare anche i resti di
quegli organismi che sono detti a corpo
molle ovvero che non hanno uno scheletro
o delle conchiglie che sono dure
mineralizzate
è proprio qui riusciamo a trovare per
esempio gli insetti molluschi come le
stelle marine oppure le piante e nei
vertebrati come i famosi pesci di Polka
riusciamo a trovare anche i resti della
pelle della pigmentazione degli organi
interni e degli occhi voi vi chiederete
Ma i fossili sono tutti così ovviamente
no nella maggior parte dei casi i
fossili sono formati da resti di parti
dure Quindi gli scheletri le ossa le i
denti e le conchiglie e questi di solito
hanno una preservazione che si dice
bassa perché sono appunto frammentate ed
incomplete infatti la documentazione
paleontologica il registro fossile è
proprio definito incompleto Ma perché è
incompleto
perché prima di diventare un fossile la
carcassa deve trasformarsi in un deve
trasformarsi in un fossile Veramente Ma
come si fa a diventare un fossile Allora
il problema qual è È che appena dopo la
morte quello che avviene è che tutte le
cellule che compongono un organismo si
decompongono letteralmente entrano in
autodistruzione e lo scheletro se
l'organismo ne aveva uno anche si
disarticola perdi di coesione e quindi
iniziamo a perdere le informazioni
ovviamente Dobbiamo considerare anche
tutti quegli organismi che si cibano
delle carcasse come per esempio Appunto
Gli avvoltoi questi possono mangiare le
carni e distruggere le parti molli e
possono anche disperdere le ossa poi
abbiamo gli agenti atmosferici anche che
sono oggettivamente importanti hanno un
impatto sui resti di animali e vegetali
li trasportano li frammentano li
distruggono Ma se foste un fossile già
formato dentro una roccia saresti al
sicuro ovviamente no perché a quel punto
una serie di processi geologici potrebbe
cancellarvi completamente dalla faccia
della terra capite bene che quindi per
diventare un fossile serve un pizzico di
fortuna come pure serve un pizzico di
fortuna per ritrovarlo nelle rocce
per darvi
un'immagine visiva di Cosa significa
questa costante perdita di informazioni
qui vedete una rappresentazione di un
ecosistema Marino del passato basato
sulle sulle sui ritrovamenti che sono
effettivamente stati fatti sul terreno
Attenzione però che dello squalo abbiamo
trovato solamente un singolo dente non
il corpo intero solo un denti isolato
dei Coralli potremmo aver trovato
tantissimi piccoli frammenti e dei pesci
stessa cosa potremmo aver trovato delle
scaglie isolate Oppure delle ossa magari
delle vertebre se siamo stati fortunati
Ovviamente questi sono i fossili
comunque importanti perché ci dicono che
siamo effettivamente Osservando i resti
di un ecosistema Marino Ma le
informazioni a livello di biodiversità
di questi ecosistema sono estremamente
limitate perché è limitato il nostro
dato sul fossile Se invece lavoriamo con
un sito fossilifero eccezionale come
quello per esempio della pesciera di
Bolca
la situazione cambia completamente
perché qui come vi dicevo prima abbiamo
mi resti anche di quegli organismi che
effettivamente sono formati solo da
parti molli e qui li troviamo nei
fossili
come come succede questo processo
succede che quando le carcasse qui a
Bolca o alla piscina si sono depositati
si sono depositate su un fondale povero
di ossigeno e sono state ricoperte da un
sedimento finissimo che ha fatto sì che
tutti quei processi di decomposizione
fossero drasticamente rallentati questo
ha fatto anche iniziare tutta una serie
di processi chimico-fisici sulla scala
del tempo geologico che hanno
letteralmente trasformato i tessuti
molli le componenti cellulari e
molecolari originali in qualcosa di
stabile in un materiale resistente al
trascorrere del tempo e così si sono
preservati fino ad oggi
Ognuno di questi fossili ha quindi Una
storia incredibile da raccontare che ci
fa da Ponte Tra il passato il presente
ma anche il futuro del nostro pianeta la
storia che vi racconto oggi ha come
protagonista un pesce luna di 48 milioni
di anni che noi abbiamo deciso di
chiamare Teddy in onore in realtà di un
altro pesce luna che è diventato
abbastanza famoso grazie ad un film
della Pixar la specie in questione si
chiama mané romblea ed è una specie
Iconica delle faune di Bolca con
centinaia di esemplari che sono stati
ritrovati ed oggi sono conservati in
tantissimi musei sia italiani che
stranieri la cosa interessante di questa
specie che in realtà il genere mene che
fa parte della famiglia dei Medici
contiene oggi una singola specie vivente
che vive nell'oceano Indo Pacifico
quindi mettete un esemplare come esempio
questa specie si chiama specie maculata
e la riconosciamo Grazie a questo
caratteristico aspetto maculato del
dorso da cui deriva il nome specifico ma
anche dal caratteristico corpo
appiattito e da queste pinne lunghe e
sottili sul ventre di questa specie
conosciamo le modalità di creatività e
la dieta ovviamente sappiamo che vivono
in banchi quindi in gruppi e si cibano
di piccoli organismi piccoli
invertebrati come molluschi e crostacei
che vivono sui fondali poco profondi
lungo le coste di tutti questi
continenti che si affacciano sull'oceano
indopacifico ora la cosa interessante di
questa famiglia di pesci luna e che da
un punto di vista scheletrico si
assomigliano tutti moltissimo Infatti
per molto tempo abbiamo pensavamo nei
paleontologi comunque gli esperti che si
occupano dello studio di questa specie
in particolare pensavano che anche le
specie del passato quindi quelle ormai
estinte avessero le stesse abitudini di
vita la stessa dieta e perché no anche
l'aspetto esterno uguale o simile a
quella della specie del presente perché
letteralmente è impossibile distinguerli
al livello scheletrico Ma è proprio qui
che invece è arrivato Ted il nostro
pesce luna che ha sconvolto un po' tutti
noi in realtà quando è stato scoperto e
abbiamo iniziato a studiarlo perché ci
ha cambiato completamente la prospettiva
ricerca dell'evoluzione di questi pesci
e ve lo dico sinceramente che Ted è uno
degli esemplari meglio preservati dal
punto di vista sia scheletrico ma anche
dei tessuti molli
come potremmo vedere presto sulla slide
come potete vedere lo scheletro è
completamente preservato è completo
tutte le parti sono lì però vedete anche
che c'è molto materiale scuro di colore
nero che fa il contorno del corpo di
questo pesce questo Noi paleontologi lo
chiamiamo materiale organico materia
organica che già suggerisce che è
qualcosa di intrinseca del fossile che
potrebbe essere originale di quando il
fossile era ancora un pesce in vita
quello che a me ha catturato in
particolare è stato proprio il contorno
del corpo che appare come una patina di
colore scuro sul dorso che poi
schiarisce in tonalità più chiare sul
ventre ma non è tutto perché nella parte
del dorso troviamo anche delle strie che
vanno dalla testa alla coda e che hanno
sono chiaroscure questo già vi fa vedere
che in realtà questo pesce avesse
probabilmente una livrea striata e non
maculata come quella della specie
attuale quindi c'è già una bella
differenza Poi se continuiamo a
osservare il fossile vediamo anche che
ci sono
un'abbondanza di strutture sempre
formate da questo materiale organico
nell'addome e anche qui l'addome è una
zona estremamente interessante da un
punto di vista biologico tutti gli
organi vitali Sono all'interno
dell'addome E così ho deciso di studiare
questa parte un pochino meglio e proprio
mentre mi trovavo al museo di storia
naturale di Verona
e stavo utilizzando un microscopio
ottico proprio mentre guardo la pancia
di Ted Noto un agglomerato di piccole
scaglie e piccole vertebre tutte
disarticolate tra loro ma raggruppate in
una zona specifica della pancia di Ted
quella dove io mi aspetterei di trovare
i resti dello stomaco grazie alla
collaborazione con il professor Giorgio
carnevale dell'università di Torino
abbiamo capito a chi appartengono questi
questi resti disarticolati ad una
sardina letteralmente Quindi quello che
io stavo osservando in quel momento
erano i resti parzialmente digeriti
all'interno dello stomaco di un pesce
luna di 48 milioni di anni che è vissuto
in un mare tropicale che per oggi è
fossilizzato sui Monti Lessini Ma qui
l'informazione importante anche proprio
quello che implica perché fino in quel
momento nessuno nella comunità
scientifica nessuno nel mondo aveva mai
osservato il contenuto dello stomaco di
un pesce luna fossile non avevamo mai
scoperto qual era la loro dieta mentre
oggi la sappiamo e questa cosa l'abbiamo
scoperto studiando un fossile di Polka
Ora ovviamente a me rimaneva da
chiarificare un pochino meglio cosa è
questa materia organica perché
sicuramente tra di voi nel pubblico ci
sarà chi pensa Sì ma come facciamo a
sapere che questi sono resti organici di
un fossile di 48 milioni di anni come
facciamo a sapere che quella è veramente
la pelle Allora cosa ho fatto ho
campionato quindi ho prelevato un
piccolo campione dal dorso dall'addome e
dall'occhio Questo è un millimetro
quadrato di materiali pochissimo
materiale e l'ho analizzato al
microscopio elettronico a scansione che
è un potentissimo microscopio che ci
permette di osservare oggetti ultra
microscopici e poi ho fatto delle
analisi chimiche specifiche per cercare
di caratterizzare un pochino meglio a
livello molecolare eventuali molecole
biologiche preservate quello che ho
scoperto al microscopio elettronico è
stato questo una miriade un numero
incalcolabile di questi oggetti
tridimensionali ovoidali con una
lunghezza di circa un micron Che
significa un millesimo di millimetro
qualcosa di piccolissimo
le analisi chimiche mi danno come
risultato una macromolecola un pigmento
un polimero che ha la stessa struttura
molecolare di un pigmento che noi oggi
conosciamo molto bene la melanina Quindi
quello che io stavo osservando qui sono
degli organelli cellulari fossilizzati
che vengono chiamati melanomi i
melanosomi fossilizzati non sono più una
novità nella paleontologia sono stati in
realtà scoperti più di un decennio fa ma
noi continuiamo a studiare proprio la
loro evoluzione a livello di quali
organismi ne avevano in passato e che
tipo di funzioni questi potevano
ricoprire i melanosomi noi li abbiamo
Oggi per esempio i nostri capelli nei
nostri occhi nella nostra pelle e qui
producono una varietà di colorazioni nel
mondo animale per esempio soprattutto
nei vertebrati eh producono il nero il
marrone il giallo l'arancione anche
alcune tonalità di blu questo significa
Però allora che se noi troviamo questi
organelli fossilizzati nella pelle di un
fossile noi possiamo ricostruire o avere
un'informazione un dato diretto sulla
loro colorazione originale sul loro
aspetto corpo esteriore ma non è tutto
per chi melanosomi oggi sappiamo sono
anche interni e ve lo dico perché io
stessa ho fatto degli studi di questi e
sappiamo che sono all'interno degli
organi come il fegato oppure il cuore i
polmoni la milza i reni e Qui hanno di
nuovo funzioni protettive Ma la cosa
interessante è che sono hanno delle
geometrie e una chimica specifica a
seconda dell'organo in cui vengono
accumulati Quindi significa che se noi
troviamo questi melanosomi fossilizzati
nell'addome per esempio di un pesce
fossile possiamo ricostruirne anche
l'anatomia interna e non solo il colore
e infatti questo è quello che siamo
riusciti a fare proprio con Ted avevo
identificato vari organi Ancora
preservati grazie alla preservazione di
Milano Sony ora c'è da mettere insieme
Un po' tutto queste informazioni e
cercare di interpretarle sulla base di
quello che noi sappiamo però delle faune
a pesci di oggi e per esempio le strie
longitudinali noi le troviamo in quei
pesci che
agiscono insieme che quindi sono formano
un banco un gruppo e però vivono nello
specifico in acque aperte quindi in
quegli Habitat in quegli ambienti che
sono poveri di punti di riferimento qui
i singoli individui riescono ad
orientarsi nello spazio proprio grazie
alle strie longitudinali presenti sul
dorso del proprio vicino Inoltre un
motivo striato lo vediamo nello
specifico in quelle specie di pesci che
mangiano altri pesci e che quindi si
dicono che sono più scivole Ora se voi
vi ricordate un po' quello che vi ho
raccontato oggi Queste sono le stesse
identiche informazioni che abbiamo
osservato su Ted Quindi significa che i
pesci Luna di Bolca erano finemente
striati come aspetto esteriore vivevano
in banchi ma in acque aperte poi
nuotavano verso la costa per nutrirsi di
piccoli pesci come le sardine
Però allora si ricapitoliamo ancora un
po' significa che nell'arco di almeno 48
milioni di anni i pesci l'una sono
cambiati non sono rimasti uguali a se
stessi ma perché questa cosa ci
interessa perché sono qua a parlarvene
perché il registro fossile della
famiglia dei Medici ci dice che sono
esistite molte più specie in passato che
oggi si sono estinte e sono vissute in
tutto il mar della tetide che L'Antico
mare Che ricopriva gran parte
dell'Europa durante il cenozoico lei era
geologica che si è susseguita subito
dopo l'estinzione dei dinosauri ora
quello che sappiamo oggi è che questa è
questa questa specie la specie del mene
maculata Quella attuale è l'unica
superstite e vive però in un ambiente
molto ristretto dei nostri oceani non la
troviamo in tutti i nostri oceani e
questo andamento lo abbiamo osservato in
altre famiglie di pesci che si sono
evolute proprio durante il cenozoico che
in realtà è stata un'era geologica molto
tumultuosa da un punto di vista di
cambiamenti a livello di movimenti
tettonici e di ristrutturazione degli
Habitat Marini
questi cambiamenti sono parte integrante
della vita del nostro pianeta non ci
possiamo fare niente succederanno anche
in futuro Quindi significa che dobbiamo
avere più Strumenti possibili per
cercare di capire quanto meno come
potrebbero andare le cose in futuro e
tra questi strumenti abbiamo lo studio
dei fossili abbiamo la documentazione
paleontologica dalla nostra parte
Ovviamente quello che è certo è che
della specie dei della famiglia dei
pesci Luna solamente una specie oggi è
sopravvissuta a tutti questi cambiamenti
ma oggi sappiamo per con certezza con un
dato scientifico che ci sono stati degli
adattamenti ci sono stati dei
cambiamenti a con adattamenti ai nuovi
habitat di vita hanno una dieta e c'è
stato anche un cambiamento della livrea
dell'aspetto di questi pesci e nello
specifico noi sappiamo molto bene come
questo accade accade grazie a specifiche
mutazioni genetiche e nello specifico
conosciamo bene quali sono i geni e
quali mutazioni questi causano per
portare una livrea striata ad una
maculata questo però cosa ci dice allora
che gli stessi identici meccanismi
genetici sono successi anche in passato
e questo non è più un'ipotesi abbiamo le
prove dirette oggi con i fossili di
Bolca
questo per dirvi quanto sono importanti
gli studi paleontologici perché è ovvio
che lo studio del presente ci aiuta ad
interpretare il passato ma è lo studio
del passato che ci dà la forza e ci dà
tutte le carte in regola per cercare di
capire come andranno le cose in futuro
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]